[Musique]
bonsoir guy millière merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rtl france un plan
montant vertigineux l'équivalent du pib
de l'italie ça y est joe biden vient de
le signer il fait la part belle à la
lutte contre la pandémie c'est en tout
cas ce que présente à ce que disent les
démocrates est ce que c'est vraiment le
cas puisque les républicains disent que
seuls 9 % ce plan est dédié à la lutte
contre l'épidémie
lorsque lise les républicains est
parfaitement exact il n'ya seulement 9 %
de toutes celles astronomique qui est
consacrée à la lutte contre le coc vide
le reste de l'argent et pour partie de
l'argent qui devait être effectivement
distribués aux familles ça va être
distribuée de manière très indistincte
je dirais que la somme de 1400 $ qui est
prévue va être donné à des gens qui en
ont réellement besoin des gens qui sont
dans les difficultés à des gens qui sont
au chômage
mais cette somme va être également
distribuées à des gens qui n'a
aucunement besoin par exemple si je
comment cas personnel je n'en ai pas
besoin je vais recevoir 2800 $ pour moi
et pour mon épouse nous n'avons pas
besoin donc que je dirais que c'est de
l'argent inutilement ni distribuer et
puis le plus grave de tout cela c'est
que l'essentiel de l'argent qui est
inclus dans ce plan va servir à
renflouer des états qui sont dans des
difficultés économiques financières
parce qu'ils ont été mal géré l'état de
new york l état de californie par
exemple
et cet argent et de l'argent qui est
d'être très très largement gaspiller et
le point le plus grave dans cet argent
c'est que c'est un genre la relève ne ce
que l'on peut appeler une relance par la
demande de type keynésien en effet on va
faire tourner la planche à billets on va
mettre beaucoup plus d'argent en
circulation cela ne peut que conduire à
de l'inflation d'ailleurs l'inflation a
déjà commencé quand on met beaucoup plus
d'argent en circulation que ce qui
pourrait correspondre à l'augmentation
de la masse monétaire poisson à
l'augmentation
du produit intérieur brut c'est ce qui
se passe et je dirais que c'est d'autant
plus grave que ça se passe dans un
contexte où alors que avant l'arrivée de
baden avant l'élection mbaye donne il y
avait une économie qui était en train de
repartir
beaucoup de décisions qui ont été prises
par l'administration by donne sont des
décisions qui sont contraires à la
possibilité pour les entreprises
d'investir et qui au contraire sont très
négatives pour les investissements donc
on abîme l'offre on détériore l'offre et
en même temps on injecte de l'argent
pour la demande
je dirais que cela ne mal ciblés et trop
de dettes
oui bien sur la dette va augmenter gérée
clé la plupart des économistes
américains pensent qu'à la fin de la
présidence byden au bout de quatre ans
il y aura environ 11 trillions de
dollars de plus de dette
agrican qui est absolument considérable
et ceci dans un contexte où on va
détériorer
l'appareil productif américain je dirais
que ça a commencé dès le premier jour où
joe biden a été élu puisqu'il a décidé
d'arrêter le questionne 'pipeline' et
d'arrêter l'exploitation de gaz et de
pétrole de schiste sur les terres
fédérales
ce sont des décisions très négative
économiquement qui ont été prises de
cette façon là donc compenser ces
décisions négatives économiquement par
de la distribution d'argent qu'on n'a
pas en faisant tourner la planche à
billets ce n'est pas une façon de
construire une économie très saine et je
dirais que ont beaucoup de gens parlent
de victoire et son prix en place dans le
contexte français
j'aiderai c'est pas du tout une victoire
c'est pas du tout triomphalisme
rien de triomphaliste a proclamé
l'économie américaine il ya un an était
la plus saine que le pays ait connu
depuis 50 ans la croissance au troisième
trimestre de l'année 2020 et est reparti
dans le rythme record de 33 8% en rythme
annuel donc les états unis n'est pas
besoin d'un sauvetage économique
ils avaient besoin d'un retour au
dynamisme plein et entier de l'appareil
productif et je dirais que ce qui est
sain pour une population
c'est le plein emploi c'est d'avoir des
emplois ça n'est pas de recevoir des
subventions du gouvernement qui versent
ces subventions de l'argent qu'il doit
prélever parce que ni la toile ce plan
est aussi est présenté comme un plan de
lutte contre la pauvreté inédit depuis
des années 60
certains se verront plutôt une bonne
nouvelle et un plan louable un pour les
plus pauvres et il y en a évidemment
plein aux états unis et aux états unis
surtout après cette pandémie
je dirais que là qu'on votait à
augmenter pendant la pandémie le chômage
aussi le chômage
à l'automne dernier il était en train de
reculer très très nettement et je dirais
que si les choses s'étaient poursuivies
sur cette lancée au deuxième trimestre à
1021 je pense qu'on ne voie était de
retour aux états unis au plein emploi
qui existait au mois de mars de l'an
dernier là nous ne serons pas dans cette
situation la pauvreté était aussi en
train de reculer la pauvreté avait
considérablement reculé pendant les
années tram est la remontée très
fortement parce qu'il ya toutes les
fermetures occasionnés par la pandémie
mais je savais que la meilleure façon de
reculer fait reculer la pauvreté
c'est d'avoir une économie en croissance
c'est d'avoir des entreprises qui
investissent c'est d'avoir des
entreprises dynamiques et c'est d'avoir
des emplois qui se créent
ce n'est pas de distribuer de l'argent
qu'on n'a pas c'est une situation très
très malsaine qui secret quand on
distribue l'argent qu'on n'a pas et
c'est hélas ce que pelé d'administration
byden en ce moment
rapidement guy millière joe biden a
annoncé avec aussi cet argent l'achat de
100 millions de doses de vaccins
supplémentaires
et quand même de quoi sortir les états
unis du marasme a quant à cette pandémie
selon vont tout de même
et actuellement les ennemis est en train
de s'effacer d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui doit prendre
forme aussi en europe
vous avez de plus en plus d'états aux
états unis où on a levé toutes les
fermetures toutes les mesures de
confinement
on a levé l'obligation du port du masque
et jeudi reste un mouvement qui doit se
répandre qui la tâche d'huile et je
savais que si je regarde la situation à
las vegas ou jeudi les spectacles sont
interrompues mais la plupart des
entreprises ont recommencé à tourner les
restaurants tourne à 50% de leurs
capacités
on est en fin de pandémie actuellement
et j'ajouterai que ceux qui auraient été
les gants de la part de joe biden c'est
de dire qu'une large partie de dés des
avancées pour la lutte contre le
coronavirus qu'il s'attribue avait été
mise en place sous donald trump
si les vaccins existent ce parce que
donald trump avait lancé une opération
qui s'appelle world speed c'est grâce à
cette opération que les vaccins existent
et la distribution de vaccins étaient
totalement connues dans l'administration
trump et donc joe biden bénéficient des
acquis de l'administration troc mais il
n'a pas le d'élégance de l'otiv ans
merci guy millière chercheurs orgue et
de son institut hauteur de après trois
éditions balland et partisan de donald
trump mercier en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france